We talked a little bit about this,
uh,
over a drink we had a couple of weeks
ago,
but what about the couples that have no
kids,
couples that just say,
you know,
we're,
we're more interested in our
intellectual pursuits or traveling or
something.
You think they are really missing sort
of like a key component of,
of what life is,
right?
I do.
I really believe that.
I mean,
I think they don't.
I think the kids have a bad rap.
That's the problem.
That's also why I wrote this chapter in
part because,
you know,
you see this too,
a lot of Hollywood depictions of
children's,
very rare that you see children
portrayed knowably in,
in a,
in a Hollywood film.
You kind of saw with Harry Potter.
I liked that and that's partly why that
was so popular.
I mean those kids had some,
you know,
there were bad kids and they were good
kids and they're heroic kids.
Like they were treated pretty in some
sense,
realistically given that it was such a
magical,
you know,
enterprise and,
and,
but they had some courage and they had
some heart and they had some
rebelliousness and so,
so I liked that.
But the thing that you have to
understand about kids is they're
unbelievably good company,
you know,
and so they pay you back for your care
of them and by being ridiculously a
music there,
their little clouds and they're doing
crazy little stunts all the time and
they have a sense of humor that kicks
in.
Like I have a grandchild now that's two
and a half months old and that child can
already smile and has the beginnings of
a sense of humor.
And that's,
to me,
that's a miracle.
It is.
It.
And so they're very funny.
They're really playful.
They really,
really like you.
And you can have the kind of
relationship with them that you set out
to have.
And so that's very,
very interesting now.
And you can also,
like once I had little kids,
I spent a lot more time with them than I
did with my friends.
Say.
And the reason for that was that I
actually found it more enjoyable to do
things with little kids than with the
adults.
And the reason for that is like,
by the time you're 30,
say you've seen so much of the world
that you actually don't see the world
anymore.
And this is technically true.
Like I'm old,
I'm 55 when I walked down the street,
there's houses,
I don't look at them,
I have house icons in my memory and I
just see the house icons and,
and so the older you get in some sense,
the more what you see of the world is
your memory and that's kind of,
it's efficient,
but it's sort of dad,
you know,
and,
and artists help break through that.
They show you something as if it's new
again,
you know.
And,
and so that's why van Gogh's irises will
sell for $160,000,000.
It's like you haven't looked at flowers
since you were three.
Okay.
So the thing that's cool about having
little kid is everywhere you go.
Because we're so good at putting
ourselves in other people's bodies.
The kid revitalizes the world.
And the kid's like,
oh,
I mean that's what a two year old looks
like all the time.
They're just completely awestruck by
everything.
And you can see that again.
And that's really interesting
man.
I know you know about my love of star
wars,
but I watched empire strikes back with
my five year old at the time,
nephew.
And at the moment when darth vader told
he was his father,
I was staring at him and he loves star
wars and I was looking at him and the
way his eyes opened,
I was like,
wow.
Like what?
That,
that thing,
like that's what it's all about,
that's what it's all like as an adult.
How could I ever as a 41 year old have
that experience again?
And that's what you're talking about,
about and,
and a movie is art.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Well,
I took my daughter to see the mask with
Jim Carrey when she gets like a little
bit young for that.
Um,
and I held her on my lap during,
I think she was,
she was probably only about five,
maybe something like that.
But I took her out one night.
We went,
saw the mask and it's pretty intense and
it was like holding a,
what would you call a bundle of
electrically charged barbed wire for an
hour and a half.
She was just like that and like I said,
it was perhaps a bit much for her,
but he had the knife.
It was exactly.
But I mean you,
you,
you forget how much impact the world has
and you know,
if you bring little kids around,
old people,
you can really see this [inaudible] old
people will sit around.
Like when we first had my daughter,
when she was the first grandchild on my,
my side,
we'd take her up to this lake that I go
to see my parents that way,
the hell up in northern Alberta.
And she was like a little fire.
You know how people sit around a fire
and look at it,
they can't look away.
It's because we're all the descendants
of the first crazy chimpanzee who
couldn't keep his God dammit fire,
you know?
And that's what little kids are like
and,
and the older people just watch them
nonstop and it's partly because they're
participating in that renewal of the
world,
you know,
which is like,
it's like a reintroduction to the
unsalted paradise of being something
like that.
But it only works if the,
if you like your kids.
And so there's a disciplinary element
that's really important too.
And one of the things that modern
parents don't understand,
and I think this is because of the
exceptionally permissive ethos of the 19
sixties,
were when we developed this idea that
everything that society does to children
is bad and so don't damage your children
by putting restrictions on them.
It's like,
that's just not so wrong that it's
almost impossible.
It's why people shy away from kids
because they don't understand that you
don't have to put up with any
unpleasant.
You don't have to put up with any
unnecessary unpleasant nonsense from
children.
It's not necessary.
It's interesting.
So the.
You could almost argue that the sixties
led to exactly what you're talking
about.
These kids who then were taught to be
afraid of everything.
They become a mess there,
the parents have now,
and that's probably in part why they're
having less children or at least talking
about family and children in a
different way when there's.
There's also less trust in the structure
of the family because the divorce rate
has proliferated and it's hard.
Like there was a woman in our department
in the psychology department who's
allison,
what's Helen's last name?
She's going to hate me if she ever
watches this.
I can't think of it.
We'll post the full post.
You're going to get it the second week
and I hope that's right.
It's probably not.
Anyways,
she showed that if you.
If you interfere with the maternal
relationship between rats and they're
pops because children are called pops,
that you can see the detrimental effects
of that disruption three generations
later.
Right?
Yeah.
So you know,
you disrupt those early bonds,
you disrupt the familial structure that
echoes.
It takes.
It's like an oral tradition in some
sense,
you know,
because being a good mother is not just
something that you're taught.
It's something that you kind of have in
your bones.
If you were mothered properly.
Like my father was an excellent father,
especially when I was a little kid.
He really spent a lot of time with me
and I used to love it when he came home
and,
and like I have a natural affinity for
little kids and I do believe it's,
it's in large part.
That's why it's because I just know how
to react with them and it's.
I do believe it's because of the way
that I was treated when I was little
kit.
You disrupt that.
It's like lots of people don't trust
themselves as parents say because they
were hurt or they didn't have good role
models or they don't trust the familial
structure.
And so you know that all that all makes
people afraid.